You're now ready to think about really
big computations, computations where,
for instance, the problem can't fit
in the memory of a single computer.
Or calculations that need so
many operations, it
would take hundreds of years to finish
them using only a single computer.
Now when the computation is
really that big, you might ask,
can I harness the collective
power of many computers?
But to design an efficient algorithm for
such a machine, you need
a suitable abstract machine model.
And that's the goal for this lesson,
for you to develop just such a model.
This particular model and
its variants go by many names,
which you are bound to encounter as
you read the literature on your own.
These names include the Network Model,
the Distributed Memory Model,
the Message-Passing Model, the
Communicating Sequential Processes Model
and probably a zillion
others that I've forgotten.
Now personally,
I like message-passing and for
reasons you'll soon see, alpha beta.
Now if any of that seems confusing,
don't worry the basic
abstraction is really simple.
You have a bunch of computers
collectively carrying out a computation.
To coordinate,
they communicate with one another by
sending mass messages back and forth.
This message-passing style stands
in stark contrast to shared memory.
There, processes or more likely threads,
communicate by reading and
writing shared variables.
Now before you start, I think it's
really important to think big.
That's because distributed memory
computations are all about solving
problems that are really, really huge.
How huge, you ask?
Well, let's start with a quick
warm up exercise to get you
thinking about computations
at the right scale.